Wall Street Journal big news ladies and
gentlemen Joe Rogan gets new Spotify
deal worth up to $250 million hit show
to be distributed broadly including on
YouTube rather than exclusively on audio
audio streaming service all right where
we at this deal is an upfront minimum
guarantee what does that mean it means
Spotify told Joe Rogan here's what we're
going to do boss we're going to take
your show we're going to put on all
platforms every single platform
imaginable we're going to pay you $250
million upfront
guarantee but we get to sell ads on all
your content on every platform and you
got to pay us back that 250 after that
we do arev share so his original deal
was he had an exclusive deal this is my
understanding from Wall Street Journal
he had an exclusive deal where they said
we're going to pay you what was like
$200 million so that your show is only
on
Spotify many people were speculating I
was talking to people in the in the
media industry and they were like you
think Joe's going to reup this deal and
now we got the news he's coming back to
YouTube he's coming back to all
platforms with Spotify in control of how
the ads are placed and generated because
uh Spotify I believe I believe Spotify
owns megaphone someone want you want to
Google that real quick and I'm pretty
sure they do and that is basically
YouTube's ad Network how you can autop
place ads this is what uh uh megaphone
does so if you're G to like put a podast
upload a podcast you put it there then
you can place that just like on YouTube
so Spotify is basically going Broad and
they're saying like we want your content
everywhere the reason this is good
demonetization is no longer a factor Joe
Rogan in the news all the time hosts a
lot of politically spicy things and edgy
things Spotify with this bet it's not so
much that they're they're predicting
something but they're setting something
Spotify is a juggernaut if they say Joe
Rogan is is is is working with us and
we're going to sell ads on his content
demonetization is out the window YouTube
is not going to demonetize Joe Rogan's
Show when he has Alex Jones on because
Spotify is going to be like that's my
money and Google my understanding is a
is a is a is a shareholder to some
degree or there's some connection there
between the two I think Google might
have the majority or something like that
I don't know long story short even if
that's not not the case Spotify does not
want to lose money they don't think
they're going to lose money and they're
not going to let these big companies
take their money from them by taking Joe
Rogan down which means we all get to
ride the coattails of Joe Rogan's show
it's not like you're going to get
absolute free speech on most platforms
but Joe Rogan's hosted you know cont I
guests and the media's lost their mind
over it now Spotify is putting putting
money behind it on YouTube and all these
other platforms on every platform that's
like we win dude yeah this is like this
is like the uh inverse of John Stewart
coming back to the Daily Show that seems
like a desperate play for them to
install this guy to deceptively edit
reality and try to you just take the
election uh but this is like a big
cultural win you know this is very
impactful especially he's going be back
on YouTube during election will it be
election year do we know when this
starts I believe it's now I mean I don't
know when they're going
when was it it was the end of 2020 they
were like January 2021 or something he
he moved over wow so it's about time for
his contracts to expire Spotify um
announced in 2020 that it was going to
acquire megaphone for uh $235 million
wow and then it looks like the deal
didn't finalize for a little while but
I'm pretty sure it went through are you
sure it it is finalized now it just
looks like it took like a year or two to
right on so how does this affect the
sort of the leftwing industry of getting
advertisers to
boycott um you know personalities and
then somehow that that chokes off their
revenue yeah I'm not really sure well
it's B it's basically it's the end man
you think Spotify is is as as a major
player in the space is going to tolerate
that they're going to go after Joe Rogan
Google's goingon to start going and
Spotify is gonna say don't touch it cuz
that's their money now it's not yep you
think they'll listen yeah Google and
well let's see I don't know if this is
uh I pulled it up in the spring of 2019
Google announced the acquisition of the
world renowned Swedish music streaming
service Spotify Google believed the AC
in the world's most popular service blah
blah
blah did it actually they considered a
transaction amount to be quite
acceptable uh Spotify Google remain as
two independent companies in 2023 okay
so so it's not but I think basically
when you have major industries saying we
endorse this look at Dave Chappelle's
comedy you look at Bud Light sponsoring
Shane Gillis it's just like we're
winning the culture and the culture is
what leads to the politics like Donald
Trump getting elected is a component of
that when you look at all the things
that the left is doing the Democrats are
doing it's like they want to burn the
country down incite violence because
they're desperate it's like you were
saying about Ted Bundy like they the
walls are closing in man we're winning
everything do you think we we'll see a
trump on Rogan on
YouTube I don't know man it would be
epic it would be epic I you know Biden's
not going to do it he can't sit in in
one place and talk for two 2 hours his
face would fall off this is one of the
things I've started to start following
just for my own Amusement like he did
the National Prayer Breakfast early and
he spoke for 10 minutes and the year
before he spoke for 20 so it really is
dwindling how long he speaks so he
really I mean we've talked about this
with the the people who are running for
office right now uh V was really good
about this RFK is on the podcast circuit
uh they're kind of embracing these
alternative platforms but this format of
just talking for several hours is not
natural to everybody and I really don't
think it's natural to Joe Biden not not
even on the people who are running uh on
the for the conservative ticket like d
santis haly couldn't do a podcast but
Trump is a complete natural for it I
mean he goes long on his speeches just
because he wants to anyways I mean he
could talk for three hours by himself
him and Rogan eating Trump steaks just
hanging out having a good time Trump
Stakes yeah pretty sure Trump Stakes
still exist right I have no idea I
thought they were done but they could no
this is the thing about uh this this
what really you know what you know what
helped me be aware of the lies about
Donald Trump in the 20156 cycle I'm I'm
at uh Fusion in uh D in it's in Miami
it's in Durell it's like right next to
Trump Durell Golf Resort okay and so if
I'm in New York and everyone's saying oh
Trump did this Trump did that I'm like
wow that's crazy I'm like you know and
I'm and I'm I'm going on the ground I'm
meeting people and I'm like well that
one doesn't seem to make sense but then
I go to Trump Durell Trump Stakes
available on the menu Trump bottled and
Trump magazine I'm I'm fairly certain it
was all there and I went oh Trump ice
was that his companies are like
McDonald's makes their own mayonnaise
it's cheaper for Trump to make a product
internally than it is to pay a premium
to have another company do it if Trump
gets his stakes from a a big stake
company he's gonna be paying for their
you know 10% margin or whatever if he
does it all on his own as a trump stake
he saves 10% when he when he sources the
materials for his hotels and his Resorts
yeah hotels need
uh bottled water it's kind of a
microcosm of America first right always
buy from Trump yeah but then the media
kept saying that like his companies are
bankrupt and they were like you can't
even buy Trump sticks where are they at
and I was like huh they're right here
along with the taco bowl that's right
the taco bow I wonder if Trump Stakes
are still a thing no TR Trump Stakes are
unfortunately not a thing they stopped
in 2007 which is pains me really but I'm
sure they're still on the menu I'm sure
like if you get a stake at be vertical
integration going on there
it wouldn't not be so no this is also
isn't it not I feel like it' be normal
if if people shut down branches of their
business like this happens all the time
why fact that he even built a trump
stake brand is hilarious in the first
place is he not going to get credit for
that TR
Stakes know Tim you might have something
here Tim Stakes they had Trump water and
I I brought I brought uh Trump water
back to the office in New York cuz they
were all saying that Trump water went
out of business and that Trump was
bankrupt all these companies and they
loved running this line where they were
like Donald Trump has been bankrupt five
times how is he still rich and well it's
cuz the banks are popping up it's cuz he
had 500 companies so 495 were fine and
the Trump organization was fine so I
come back and I'm like oh here's the
Trump water like where'd you get this
and I'm like from Trump Hotel like
literally next to the office in Miami
they were like wow I'm like these people
have no idea what's going on in the
world God look at that picture I just
want like a sky M equivalent but it's
Trump related products like just Trump
mall and he just sells you like all
kinds of random things like popped up
independently all around the country you
know you'll see like this like this like
mainstream Wasteland and then all of a
sudden you'll see a store that's just
like the Trump store there's a lot of
them in Florida you'll see them in like
the middle of the country but you'll
just be driving along and then you'll
see just all of a sudden just a window
plastered with Trump paraphernalia it's
like a souvenir shop for like the part
of America that's voting for him like
this is this is crazy look at this in
the Wikipedia for Trump Stakes says in
August 2015 Time Magazine included Trump
Stakes on list of Trump business
failures in December 2015 during the
2016 presidential campaign a super pack
supporting John Kasich produced an ad
mocking Trump Stakes blah blah blah I
don't care dude I should totally make a
list of my business failures yeah
there's a lot right I once worked on an
app to uh facilitate political donations
on Facebook for politicians and this was
like 2009 or 10 or something very early
days it was like the app days of
Facebook and I was working with some
like how would anyone ever find out like
we worked on a project it went nowhere
we fizzled out we had like an early
prototype that couldn't really you know
then we were like ah we don't know
there's too much regulation let's do
something else the amount of things
Trump's probably worked on the funny
thing is they mock him for his failures
is it's a perfect perfect example of who
they are they have no failur they think
that's a good thing yeah but they never
tried to do anything they're averse to
risk and they don't want to fail they're
RSE to any work yes this is true that's
why they like the
pods I mean look let's let's let's let's
consider this we put them in the pods
they don't mind we give them the bugs
they also don't mind who's complaining I
don't got to eat the bugs and I'm not
going to live in the Pod but they can I
mean and they're doing it give them the
new Apple headset
yeah this is my life plan right like
just let them go and I'll stay here and
if that's what you guys want to do cool
cool cool but I don't want to in that
direction like the trend of a lot of
people growing up not having kids
they're just going to fizzle out and
also they're going to plug the neuralink
and they're going to go to their micro
universes where they're you know the
Demon Slayer and you know they got all
the busty women jumping up and down
around them yeah funny cuz they don't
like Elon right now but they also didn't
like Trump but it was Trump's vaccine
but now they love the vaccine so at some
point they'll probably like the
neuralink even though they didn't like
Elon El's mete because that's how they
that's their logic yeah no but look how
many of these these liberal people have
hidden their blue checks on Twitter true
why why sign up for the service just to
pretend like you didn't sign up for it
you know what I mean they
what a genius move by El to just hide
that though it's like the best move the
option you can hide your your
verification great move great move
that's czy you want to be a coward you
can do it I think these people are going
to line up the left is going to line up
to jump into the into the Matrix with
with smiles on their faces it's it's
their entire Mo they're gonna they're
and they're going to Advocate their kids
do it and they're gonna you know what
you're you're better off is bliss well
look the cure for depression juicy
steaks how could you be depressed right
a clinical uh um um hormonal depression
I suppose where you just don't
understand why you're you feel so your
body doesn't produce the correct amount
of Serotonin yeah or something like that
but for the average person their
listlessness and depression I love like
the funny thing about Lauren Southern
had this tweet where she said before we
give you ssris you have to go to the gym
twice a week or something and everyone's
like you don't understand some people
and she's like I'm not talking about
people who are immobile she's like if
you have the ability to go to the gym go
start working out it releases endorphins
it makes you feel better thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net